Tell me about yourself.
It's often the first question in a job interview...
...and one of the most difficult to answer.
Just because it's an open-ended question doesn't mean...
...there aren't any wrong answers.
The first trap to avoid is asking "What do you want to know?"
It might be tempting to ask for clarification.
Don't.
Another misconception is that the interviewer...
...is asking about your personal life.
You're not being asked to discuss your childhood,...
...your political or religious beliefs...
...or how you're managing a medical crisis.
Leave these personal details out of your answer.
How should you answer the question?
Use recent work experiences to show...
...why you'll be good at the job you're applying for.
Be brief.
Don't take more than a minute.
And most importantly, rehearse your answer.
Practice speaking your answer over and over...
...so you can repeat it naturally,...
...even under the stress of an interview.
Tell me about yourself is a vague question,...
...but having a concise answer can get your interview off to a great start.